[Applause]
whether it was manchester
liverpool bristol or wembley the air
crackled with nervous energy
[Applause]
pubs and fan zones in fact anywhere you
could watch the game
turned into modern day coliseums
armed with heights and flags supporters
shouted and cheered
hoping their footballing gladiators
would end decades
of bitter defeat and as the match
started
it felt it really felt like that time
had come
a bouncing wave of euphoria sweeping
across city and town
as england glided into an early lead
but under a cloud of rain and drizzle
the mood
would darken this is english football
after all and it would soon be defined
by agony
i just feel like they dropped off a
little bit in the second half and i just
want them to like pick it up again
because i
i'm so nervous right now
fans became increasingly anxious as
italy equalized
their nerves finally shredding in a
high-stakes game
that would eventually end in a loss not
in extra time
but almost as though it was scripted on
penalties
watching england play is normally a
burden of suffering and tonight
it was no exception what started out
as a massive celebration is now pretty
muted
people are leaving the pubs miserable
frustrated heading home with their heads
held low it is what it is sad night to
go home
i'm absolutely going it's like i'm gonna
go home and cry i'm so proud that
england made it this far we got proud of
them
they reached the final yeah
this will still be remembered as a huge
achievement a group of diverse socially
aware players
taking england into an historic final
in a time of a long covered pandemic and
divisive culture wars
the team has managed to unite a country
for now though there is the hangover
and the thoughts of what could have been
alex rossi sky news bristol